what has been useful about having that
your chart of art thinking so you
mentioned that Amy Whitaker
you know she's trying to bring it into
into business what's been useful for you
about having this to show to people yeah
so this is the first time I presented
this diagram publicly but it's been
useful for me as a process because you
know as every artist I've had many
failures and I'm getting much better at
not making failures anymore and so one
of the things with our thinking model is
that I didn't really I kind of skipped
over this in my talk was that art
thinking let's get over to it for a
second so one thing about this model is
that art thinking and we have
discoveries that there's a failure mode
that and this is what something that Amy
Whittaker talks about that any point you
can fail in this process and it's okay
to fail like if you come to the
refinement process to the stage and you
fail you can't make and you can't really
refine the work and you kind of mind it
mind it mind it you just have to let it
go
you just have to start over and abandon
it I've made the process the problem of
getting too attached to the work and
maybe working under a deadline and then
just kind of pumping the work out
anyways and pushing through and then I
end up with this like kind of tepid
peace it doesn't quite work it's on my
website and I look at oh my god geez you
know why did I make that one and and and
so in many cases would be better just to
kind of think about each of those as
failure notes and and one things that
artists do is they work towards an arc
of failure and designers work towards an
art or success so they're trying to make
a successful project and oftentimes I'm
taking stuff in that experimentation but
and hoping it will fail like like will
this hopefully fail if it fails and I
can just drop it and do something else
[Music]